hey you guys
it's monday sorry we were laughing
because uh yeah
pokey's over there playing she's right
there it's like playing with her little
toys like stomping on him like a little
bunny rabbit like ah die toys die oh
[ __ ] i'm not in the mood i'm not getting
it yeah getting out of the damn frame
i'm not in the movie you're not in the
movie you're in the you're in the next
video
on youtube who knows what that is cam
guy just said he just saw scanners
i said he liked it he said it held up
real well
yeah he said i couldn't tell who really
won in the end i think cameron went into
his brother and so they were both in
that one dude's body yeah yeah
i don't remember what happened in the
sequel did they like address what
happened there
remember maybe that sequel was terrible
it's not it's not a uh it's not the same
director
well yeah obviously
block frog says hey are you guys gonna
eventually do the shitty uh haunting
episodes yeah it might probably be fun
to do like some of the [ __ ]
yeah i mean it seems like everybody
wanted us to do like the good ones first
i mean other than the other good ones
that we covered a long time ago yeah but
now the shitty ones you talk about some
of the newer ones yeah the later they're
probably pretty shitty i mean like i
said i think a bunch of them are maybe
on
to be or pluto or something like that
like i think you can see them like some
places yeah because i think there's like
12 or 13 or 14 seasons or something yeah
and i think we stopped watching in like
eight or nine maybe people are still
people are still coming in yeah the um
saw prey last night it was pretty good i
liked it well we could do a review of
that tomorrow probably pretty good but
you can see it free on hulu
yeah well i mean hulu's not free but
well
but if you subscribe to who you can see
it for free yeah i mean i have hulu
that's so i think it's only eight
dollars it's like 804
a month or something
it's one of the better ones i think it's
in the top four
yeah
um yeah blackrock said uh oh yeah the
good ones first for sure and the newer
ones are the ones i was talking about
yeah i'm actually kind of curious to see
some of the newer we've seen some of the
newer ones
but i don't think i've seen all the new
ones because the old ones like we have a
bunch of them like on the physical media
and we've seen them a bunch of times
yeah and and uh even in some of the
classic ones from like the first four or
five six seasons there are a few of them
in there that are
bad or clunky not bad they're just just
not real memorable they're not real
memorable kind of boring and you're not
really sure if there's much to the case
because there's
it's just testimony
yeah i mean yeah and so there doesn't
seem to be and a lot of times there
isn't a lot of witnesses to the story so
you don't know you know you just got to
take the story at its word at face value
i mean this one seemed like a good
episode though i mean they did have a
lot of people that worked there that
were saying but you know what i found
like another pretty um intensive like
write-up about this place about the late
club on uh a site called american
hauntings inc it's called
and um
they kind of went into some stuff like
the history of the club and everything
like that but they went into the story
by him and some of the stuff that the
witnesses said happened would have been
actually really cool if they'd show her
on the show but they didn't put it on
the show oh so there's there was stuff
missing yeah nothing like major major
but just like some of the stuff they
should was like a little bit different
than
what they described but i think that
usually happens but it's weird because
like i said sometimes and i think we
talked about this on one of the other
episodes too is that sometimes you would
think that if somebody said something
happened that was like really horrific
that they would want to show it but
sometimes like on a haunting maybe
because they can't afford the special
effects or something like that maybe
that's what it is because you think they
want to show because it was like
creepier but
you know
uh one of these days you should review
the film usual suspects yeah i've
actually been wanting to for quite a
while
but
zack says a fun fact about this episode
the club in real life i think is located
in illinois yeah it is it's in
springfield illinois but the one they
used in the show was in arkansas yeah
sony was talking about that they used
the porsche 911 in this that was like
one of the coolest things in the series
they did yeah that was like yeah that's
right the the guy was like driving here
and pulled it up to the thing yeah
watching this episode kind of uh kind of
like the urban urban exploration video
this that old architecture so that 70s
80s architecture kind of like a dab
bricks and right angles and square boxy
then you go in there and you know just
it's kind of cool on the kind of cool
interior on the inside kind of retro
it's kind of a good it's kind of a
kind of a good episode i liked it it's
not one it's
i'm gonna say
it's a better than average episode it's
not really one of my favorites yeah uh
but it's better than average weird [ __ ]
happens in it or supposedly weird [ __ ]
happens in it so
you know we're gonna get to it i think
the only other one well they did bobby
mackey's that was another nightclub but
we talked about that one before yeah
because that's kind of like a famous
yeah similar to this way because it's
happening in a music club bobby mackey's
that that video
it does stand out that particular
episode yeah
um but there's something about it being
in a country western bar that's like
annoys me over and over again because
they're playing country western music
that's true yeah but i mean a good story
yeah this one is kind of interesting
because as far as i could determine
uh prior to the events in in the 1970s
which you know the people were on there
talking about this place didn't really
have a reputation of being haunted it
seemed like it was just this one thing
and then like it went away afterward
whereas i kind of feel like the bobby
mackey's thing i mean there had been
stories about that place being haunted
like before they even like bought it
yeah
no now that you're [ __ ] bringing it
fresh into my mind yeah i think about i
think i like bobby mack he's actually
better than this one now that i think
about it that was the one where the
caretaker shows up and goes oh yeah yeah
you bought this place yeah this place is
[ __ ] haunted how he used to work it
[Laughter]
and is new owner bobby bobby was like oh
that [ __ ] ain't knowing it but his wife
[ __ ] bought into it she started
seeing stuff
yeah there was a story behind it
but they think there's a story about
about a girl getting beheaded back in
the 1800s yes he was like much more
lurid
much more splashy than this one i guess
yeah but like it's still a good one
though yeah this is still a good episode
zach says i looked at the real life club
on google and it had this low ceiling
30s supper club look to it nothing like
what's in the show okay yeah in the show
it just kind of looked like a pretty
generic
something in a strip mall like a big
dance club slash live music venue with
like a big you know wooden dance floor
and they built a lot of these late 70s
early 80s in the united states they were
like a strip mall
uh they weren't enclosed it was just a
like an entire block
and they were all kind of connected and
you might have some restaurants and a
doctor's office and uh this and that and
then all of a sudden a movie theater
and then the next one would be more you
know little shops and this looks like it
was supposed to be a movie theater at
one time that was renovated into a
restaurant slash nightclub
i have a feeling i think it started out
as a restaurant like because that place
was opened well the club was open in the
40s but i think it had been around
before then but not as a nightclub i
think it was a skating rink i'm talking
about the structure that they used in
the episode oh okay which that's not the
real it's not the real place you're
saying the one that they used in the
episode that looked like a movie theater
it looked like a movie theater it did
look like converted into a into a bar
slash
[ __ ] live music event and usually
they'd have a restaurant and something
like that too because there were lots of
those
yeah and uh you know you could eat
dinner there and
drink and then you'd have a live band
tables and [ __ ] just the way it was back
in those days
yeah i mean you know 70s and 80s
and that's kind of when this took place
too although like i said the real place
now i think the real place i think is
gone because according to american
hauntings inc i think it burned down in
1992 and it had actually been abandoned
for four or five years prior to that
because i think it closed down in the
late 80s and then in the 90s um somebody
set it on fire but it had been like
abandoned for a long time prior to that
at least according to that website
so
are you i think we got a full cast are
you ready to get into it yeah so yeah
the late club horror it's episode it's
actually season one episode six so we're
still doing season one everybody just
seems to like the season one ones the
most i think those were kind of like the
best ones
there's something about them yeah some
about them but the the the the series
or the yeah
what is it
the property what do you call it this uh
[ __ ]
is i guess you'd call it a series right
yeah yeah it's serious yeah it's a
series the series was kind of young and
fresh
it was news it had a lot of energy in
the way that things were filmed and the
the actors were good but that went on a
long time man yeah it went on
five six seasons you know it stayed
strong the the problem was it was uh it
started to run out of cases
and it got sold to another company after
this one but
they uh
they tried to keep uh
the quality up but you could tell that
the budget went down
yeah i think that was kind of a big
issue too i mean it's not like this show
had like a massive budget or anything
like that but
it had like a decent look to it and
had some like okay special now it was
under the impression that
the company that was the second company
to buy this property
or to buy this series
i think was religious i think it was a
church
i kind of suspected that as well just
because of the way it was leaning hard
into like everything being demons and
and the church saving everything and the
church saving everything and [ __ ]
which the early seasons had like
sometimes had that but like usually
didn't really have a trope every time a
lot of times it was per it was uh
parapsychology
uh there was there was just something
churchy about
when they handed it over i guess that
they think they may have handed it over
to another company yeah it'd be like it
definitely had a church season five or
six around that time
kind of had a churchy vibe danny rowling
said uh series ones the first season was
the cement foundation while season four
was the grand finale of a firework show
in my opinion
black frog also said uh also what i
think made the early ones way better was
the technology implemented in the
episodes the new ones have really cheesy
eyes uh
cgi goes i was trying to say cheesy and
cgi at the same time uh and it just
isn't scary yeah i kind of feel like
that's what's creepier about the old
ones they don't show as much yeah and it
was practical effects yeah it was like
it was cheap it was you know it was a
lot like creepy there was something
creepy about them it was cuddled and
they were kinda you know better than
some of the old retro horror movies like
you know like emily vahre they were
better than that yeah and you got
they would play them just [ __ ] run
them all day long on damn what was it
our [ __ ] history chat no it was art
entertainment what what channel what did
we see this on destination america
destination america for a while for that
was later
i think they started i think it started
on discovery didn't discover your a and
e or something
something like that
and um they'd play them all day long so
if you weren't at work you could just
sit there and [ __ ] watch six seven
episodes of them and zone out
and get creeped out sometimes
you're like wow especially me because
you know [ __ ] i had some poltergeist
[ __ ] happen to me and my family when i
was a kid so
i didn't take all these for i knew
better to take everything
at fit you know at its word that you
just gotta understand that you know i
knew that it was
these are stories based upon people not
all of them would be honest and then
sometimes you know
the uh uh the director himself would
kind of soup up the story a bit because
if you try to dig into the story and
find out that you know it didn't quite
the witnesses didn't say it quite
happened like that but you i knew it was
entertainment it was just some of the
[ __ ] was [ __ ] like plausible to me i
was like yeah that sounds like something
that happened
you know
zack says uh okay the club in the
episode is called the norva club and
it's actually in norfolk virginia
opened as a movie theater in 1922. okay
uh sebastian asks has anyone heard of
castle rock yes i haven't seen i've seen
like the first few episodes and i like
those but i never did finish it i bought
the dvd only five pounds yeah that was
like a series based around the works of
stephen king
so he's not really involved in it is he
um i'm not sure i think he signed off on
it but it's almost kind of like the
series like it's almost kind of like an
extended universe like with all his
books some reason i'm thinking that i'd
heard from somebody
that would reviewed it said that it
wasn't that good that it's kind of
floundered i don't think it's on anymore
is it i don't know i only saw like the
first few episodes and i quite liked
those but i just lost track of it and i
kind of started watching other stuff i
think they kind of wanted it to be
something kind of like stranger things
but it evidently didn't work out i never
seen it but just what i heard well you
haven't seen strange things either no i
keep trying to get you to watch it
because i think i've seen a few episodes
of it yeah the quality looked real good
i think he really liked it the quality
looked real good on that one yeah block
frog said uh yeah exactly like the ghost
face and the summer wind episode that
freaked me out when i was younger yeah
yeah
that's what i
yeah and it was just hanging there
yeah
yeah zack said i used to where is that
raccoon
uh oh
[Music]
i paid me to put that in one of the
shows that i keep forgetting yeah okay
so all right
um
zach said i used to get so excited as a
kid when the travel channel used to do
all all afternoon long go show marathons
whereas these days it's nothing but yeah
yeah yeah because every single channel
now every time i go yeah if you go to
like the travel channel like website
it's like and you look oh what's on
right now it's always ghost shows yeah
every channel is ghost shows cable tv
[ __ ] sucks now i mean it's all i go
down to the oasis they got cable tv
playing with [ __ ] subtitles on some
of those back televisions and those some
of those losers up in there watch that
[ __ ]
and man [ __ ] tv is more mindless than
it's ever been it's just more channels
and it's just more shitty dumb well they
just have to make more things to like
fill up the time you know what i mean
rock bottom bottom of the bear it's just
kind of like we're just and reality
shows are generally cheaper to produce
than
dramatic shows i'm watching this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] i'm thinking who's watching
this
but i guess they got people in trailers
that watch that or something
old people
i guess but i'm just yeah it just seems
like all it seems like all ghost shows
or
like bigfoot shows yeah yeah the bigfoot
show still left cable tv seems to be all
very old people watching that or maybe
people that are just
too poor to have internet or something
it's just
terrible programming
terrible
they're laughing at my where is that
wrecking
i know it's like i keep waiting i said i
i keep made of i've had that for like a
couple weeks i made it a couple of weeks
ago
well i keep forgetting yeah and then i
was like well i have to put it on like
one of the haunting episodes and then
finally like when you yeah they're on
there laughing
uh zach said the stalked by evil episode
[ __ ] me up as a kid with the burnt up
guy
tormenting the team girl in her closet
oh i remember that one yeah had
nightmares because of the makeup they
did on that guy that's another one we
should probably do so i need to write
down stock well i
that's a whole notebook so do you want
to bring it to you i mean i guess
okay here i mean there's like little
bits of paper all over there there's
paper everywhere okay
i got little bits of paper all over the
place you remember that [ __ ] yeah
stalked by evil okay
i remembered what i said just make sure
you remember it i will
i have a list of them somewhere i just
have to like remember that it's like i
remember what i'm doing you know how
many how many things i got to keep track
of every day
and i remember 99 of them okay uh but
yeah okay so let's finally start talking
about this yeah yeah this episode
so i actually did we watched it last
night and then i watched it again today
like so i can make more notes about it
and like i said there is like a pretty
long write-up about the haunting that
goes a little bit more into the history
of it uh that was on a like a haunting
website american hauntings inc i think
it's called and we're drinking rum and
orange juice if you guys yeah i mean
it's monday night but it's like ah it's
a haunting we're having a good time
[Laughter]
this is all we gotta do today
uh yeah well well tonight we probably
have to watch the movie that we're gonna
be talking you like doing the uh thing
for the thing oh it's thundering outside
the thing for the thing you know the
movie retrospective yeah yeah we
probably have to watch that tonight all
right so
as we mentioned earlier this club the
late club uh is in springfield illinois
so we open in the summer of 1974.
and the club is owned by two guys now on
the show they called them philip dean
and tony barbato i don't think that
those are the real names of the owners
like the guys that rented it and were
like on the show talking
that's their real names but as far as i
know like the owners names that they
used on the show were not their real
names
um so they show the club to this guy who
wants to rent the place named bill
carmine and he was on there
so bill said you know it was 1974 i had
had a construction business with my dad
and my brother but there was all this
energy crunch like nobody was building
as much so their business was kind of
tanking so they were all looking for
another investment
so the late club was kind of a
well-known uh thing in the area like i
said it had been around i mean at least
as a club since the 40s and they'd had
like ella fitzgerald and not king cole
and mickey rooney and just like bob hope
and like all kind of like super famous
people so it was like really really well
known in the area and it seemed like it
was going through like a little bit of a
resurgence like right around this time
so they thought it would be like a good
thing to invest in now the club had been
closed when they went into rennet for
the previous six years i believe it
closed in 1968
and so
they said but the owners had been
keeping it up really well they said they
went in there and they said it was
pretty much he said it's pretty much
turnkey like you could just come in all
we needed was the liquor license and to
book some bands it had all the glassware
it had all the everything it was like
all really kept up
so they said okay fine
now the first thing they show on the
show
is bill uh he's in the hall on the way
to the office when the owner is like
showing him the place
and he hears something that sounds like
giggling like down the hall now he
didn't say that he heard that but that's
what they showed on the show and i'm
going to say that a lot like on this
right well like no one was there
now while he's finalizing the contract
with the owner uh bill's there in the
office and bill notices this kind of
hole in the ceiling that looks like it's
been covered up a little bit or there's
like some weird [ __ ] on the ceiling
right and he asked the owner he's like
hey what's going on over there it's like
like leaking or something and they're
just like oh that's nothing it's it's
not a problem and then um he asked the
caretaker whose name is dusty but who i
call deadhead dusty because he looked
like the quintessential
deadhead guy like with the long stringy
hair and like the thing the
the little uh
bandana like wrapped around his forehead
and his little like round glasses or
whatever
yeah he had this so deadhead dusty uh
can fix that it's fine
so
bill i guess before the place opens
he's spending like a really long time in
the club by himself you know getting
ready for you know people to come in
there
now one afternoon this is kind of the
first major thing that happens i guess
like one afternoon he's in there alone
and he distinctly said he heard the
piano in the back playing like someone
was playing it for like quite a long
time it seemed like
and he's like what the [ __ ] it's just
like nobody's supposed to be in here so
he goes in the back it almost looked
like the i guess it was like the green
room type thing like where the bands go
before they go out on stage and they had
a piano in there so he goes in there and
he's like there's absolutely
nobody in the place he's like the cover
is over the keys and everything and he's
just like i know i [ __ ] heard that um
but nobody was in there
so creepy
so the club opens to the public in
autumn 1974 and he said the first night
i guess word had gotten around that it
was reopening so they were like totally
slammed he's like we ran out of ice we
ran out of beer we were out of booze
it's like we ran out of everything we
were ready
we weren't ready but um he said but they
got more stuff for the second night and
it was fine and he says that actually
the club was like really like you know
successful like for a while and he said
they were doing so well that he realized
he's like i'm not gonna be able to run
this [ __ ] by myself because it's so busy
so he brings on a manager a guy named
tom blasco now tom blaska was a musician
and his band had played there a bunch of
times and he was friends with bill so he
was like yeah you know i'll pay you
however much a week and you can like run
the place when i'm not here you know
what i mean just like to help out
so the co-workers kind of all became
very close one bartender in particular
barbara was interviewed on the show i
think her last name was lard actually
which is unfortunate but um she said she
started working on the at the club when
she was 21.
now
one night after closing tom kind of
shows everyone out at the end of the
night and then he notices that the
inside of the club is like ice cold he
said it just
he's like it was a weird
like really really cold like feeling
so he goes down to the basement to see
if something's wrong with the air
conditioning or something like that
now while he was down there he said he
felt like somebody was standing right
behind him but of course like he turns
around and nobody's there yeah same
thing happened to mammoth mountains like
that that cold feeling and being watched
it's weird it's not real cold though
you know i don't think
it's something spiritual or something
there's no way to tell them i don't
think if you held out a thermometer it
would register it's just some kind of
weird i've heard a lot of people say
that they said it feels cold but not
like normal
normal cold yeah yeah tim i meant to
bring that up tammy yeah olivia newton
john died oh did she yeah
73 73 she lived a full life i just saw
it on the on the thing i mean unless it
was a hoax because i think like a week
or two ago they said somebody died and
he's like hey i'm still alive yeah well
she was cute
yeah she was cute back today yeah black
frog says oh man lard i know that's what
i said too well i was like watching it
and i was watching it with the um with
the uh closed captioning on and i was
like wait did that just oh that's really
her last name oh i felt so bad for her
but yeah
that's like it sucks
so yeah he said he felt like somebody's
standing right behind him but of course
nobody's there he then apparently hears
some kind of
moan or some kind of like sound of
distress it kind of sounded like a cough
yell type of noise to me
um
but
and then on the show they implied that
he saw like a ghostly dude or a shadow
like lunging at him although i will note
that he didn't say that he saw that
they're taking liberties but whatever it
is that i don't know if it was just the
feeling of
something behind him or just a sound or
something like that but it scared him so
much
that he ran right the [ __ ] out the
basement and write the [ __ ] out the club
he said i left all the lights on i left
the ac running and everything like that
i just got the [ __ ] out of there and
didn't come back in so it must have been
like something really uh upsetting
now uh tom at first does not tell anyone
about this because he thought people
would think he was nuts which is
something a lot of people say
but that night later on when the club is
open bill uh tells tom hey i've been
having some weird [ __ ] happen to me in
this club and he tells him about like oh
the other day i heard the piano playing
and nobody was in there so they kind of
share their experiences and then they
decide well let's not really tell any of
the other employees or tell any of the
people
uh you know that are coming in because
we don't want to scare anybody or drive
business away or whatever because like
maybe in the 70s if you told people your
[ __ ] was haunted everybody's like oh i'm
not going there anymore whereas nowadays
if you said it was hot everybody's like
i want to go there you know what i mean
maybe it was different in the 70s i
can't really remember early 80s if you
said something was haunted they think
you were [ __ ] crazy
well and this was like
mid-70s yeah
i'm just wondering like
if you said stuff was haunted back then
it probably would have kept people away
like i said now it's like people
now like bed and breakfast and stuff
will go out of their way to claim that
they're haunted to get more people to
come there
you know what i mean so it's just can i
have the haunted room yeah
which one would you like
which haunted room would you we've got
all the haunted rooms they're all
haunted right
you want haunted or super haunted or
ultra mega haunted yeah the most haunted
is the penthouse
500 that is like just so [ __ ] hot
yeah i mean you know what i mean you
can't keep anybody in it
yeah it's almost like you have to you
have to like dare people yeah nobody can
stay there all night oh i can do that
yeah you know what i mean they know the
tricks
all right so all that happens but then
they're like uh so for a few weeks they
said nothing really unusual occurred
then one night bill leaves a bit early
after closing
um
it was kind of a weird conversation
because he was drinking and i didn't
know if he was implying that he was
drunk or because he said something funny
like i got a real important meeting to
go to i'm like do you mean you have to
take a dump what are you talking about i
was just i didn't really know what he
was talking about but he's like well he
had to leave right
so he has to leave so he leaves tom to
finish cashing out and doing the [ __ ]
that you have to do like after the
nightclub closes so after he leaves
tom said he suddenly heard what sounded
like a bunch of people talking out in
the hallway though he couldn't tell what
they were saying
now at this point like tom was like
freaked out by this place so he's a
catholic and so he starts carrying
around a rosary with him and also a
pistol you know just in case so you got
like you know you got he got two-handed
like [ __ ] defense there
um so he goes out in the hall still
hearing these conversations like
overlapping conversations but not seeing
anybody
now again the show implied that he saw
like a shadowy figure like rushed by a
then of all like like that
um but i don't think he he didn't say
that he saw that so i don't know if that
was just like because you think if you
saw somebody rush like that you think it
was a person and you'd run down there
after it but he didn't do that
so he turns all the lights on and kind
of searches the place top to bottom goes
out on the stage and everything like
that but he doesn't find anybody
now the next morning bill comes in and
finds all the money and everything from
the night before like left out like in
the office the safe was still open and
everything so it turns out that
tom was kind of a fraidy cat um
that whatever it was that happened that
night
uh he again he just like [ __ ] took
off he said he completely forgot about
what he was doing he's like i completely
didn't even remember running out of the
place i was just like so freaked out
that i just got out of there left money
laying around on the [ __ ] table and
everything um but he just got the hell
out of there so you know there's that
so by this time bill and tom have had so
many weird things happen that they start
they figure well we're gonna have to
start telling the other employees about
it
so barbara lard the woman we were
talking about before she doesn't believe
them at first she said it was kind of
fun to talk about like after hours we'd
all sit around and drink and like make
jokes about it and stuff but she didn't
believe
that she's like i just thought they were
joking you know what i mean and they
were just being funny
now shortly afterward there was a there
was kind of an incident where a
traveling salesman comes to the club one
morning
and bill is sitting with him listening
to his spiel or whatever
and a glass on the bar like kind of
behind bill it looks like sort of like
starts shaking right and then it picks
itself up and like throws itself against
the wall right next to the salesman's
head uh and the dude is just kind of
like what the [ __ ] and he just like yep
i'm out and he just leaves and bill said
yeah the quote was it scared the hell
out of him like yeah i guess so
so at this point bill decides maybe we
need to call in some help because you
know obviously like a ghost throwing a
glass at somebody is pretty violent and
we don't want somebody to get hurt
now that particular night
that that happened the club was like
particularly crowded
and barbara needed to use the bathroom
but the line was way too long she's like
man there's like so many [ __ ] in that
line i really have to go to the bathroom
so bill said well go use the bathroom in
the back in my office
so she goes back into the office and she
said immediately she felt like really
uncomfortable she said it was like a
really unsettling feeling back there but
she tried to write it off as maybe you
know i'm just stressed out because it's
been so busy because they said they'd
been like running 90 miles an hour
because there was just so many people
there
um but then when she so she goes in she
uses the bathroom when she comes out of
the bathroom she said
she saw a man very clearly
who told her that one of the owners was
going to die
she said it what it didn't sound like
a threat
um but it sounded like a warning she
didn't say that on the show but i saw
like another
uh thing where it had like interview
with her where she said that she said it
didn't sound like he was just like
you're gonna die [ __ ] wasn't she
like it wasn't like that it was almost
like he was warning her
uh so she screams obviously uh as you
would because she knew like immediately
that's not a person now i will note here
that on the show and i'm assuming that
they did this for probably budgetary
constraints
on the show like when they show the
ghost like talking to her it's
it's basically just a guy you know what
i mean so just like a guy but she's like
well i could tell it was a ghost in the
other thing that i read where she talked
about it
she said
that it was just his head that like just
his head was floating there which like i
said how scary how much scarier would
that have been if you just came out of
the bathroom and saw a [ __ ] floating
head like right there like talking to
you that would be like i would like
[ __ ] [ __ ] a brick if that happened
but on the show they showed like a full
body apparition and like i said i'm
assuming that's because it was probably
just like easier because they could just
like film a guy and have like creepy
makeup on him or whatever but uh yeah
she said that it was actually just a
head
so now she comes back
out into the club
and bill said she looked like she was
absolutely in terror and she was like
all panicky and stuff like that
and he's like what the [ __ ] what what's
wrong and she said i can't tell you she
said that he said that's all she kept
saying was i can't tell you i can't tell
you i can't tell you
and then he says uh you want to go back
in the office and lie down and she's
like [ __ ] no i mean she didn't say it
like that but i mean that's what she
meant she's like [ __ ] no i'm never going
back in there ever again uh please don't
make me
um so bill said okay well you can take
the rest of the night off because you
obviously have uh have a problem
now the next day um barbara
tells them what happened that she saw
this guy
and she described him like described
what he looked like but she doesn't tell
them what he said
because she explained she's like i made
the decision that i didn't you know i
told him that i saw a [ __ ] ghost
right but she's like i didn't want to
tell him that he had told me that one of
the owners was gonna die because like i
thought he was talking about one of them
and he's like i really liked both of
them and i didn't want to like scare
them or burden them or anything like
that because it was like really [ __ ]
up and yeah so she didn't want to tell
them what the warning was uh you weren't
here but
i was talking about you know the part
where she sees she comes out of the
bathroom and sees the guy like sees the
ghost uh comes out of the bathroom and
she's going and then the guy and then
the guy said one of the owners is gonna
die like interface yeah i kind of
vaguely remember that well you were kind
of drunk when you were watching the show
what did he look like well he looked
like a guy like with a mustache and [ __ ]
no i don't i don't quite remember that
part but okay what about it okay well
never mind well i was going to say that
like on the show they showed that it was
like a full body like it was a dude but
they when i saw something else that she
had talked about she said it was just a
floating head oh [ __ ] which like i said
which should have been way scarier if
they showed that on the show like a
floating head but uh yeah cause like i
said i would [ __ ] a brick if i [ __ ]
saw that
um so yeah so bill goes to see the
caretaker good old deadhead dusty
and dusty has actually worked at the
club like for a very long time so he
knew like the old owners and like all
the old employees and stuff
so bill goes and says okay um do you
know a guy that looks like this and like
describes the dude like he was like um
because this was a real life guy but he
was like they said he was real big like
real tall like a you know kind of heavy
set like um and they described like what
he looked like
um dusty says that sounds like rudy rudy
crainer who was a guy who used to
bartend there like back in the 60s
um so he has like a bunch of pictures
that we're taking because like i said
deadhead dusty's been working there for
a long time so he has a bunch of
pictures and some of the pictures have
rudy in them so he gives bill like a
whole bunch of the pictures and he's
like okay well i'm gonna show these to
barbara and see if she recognizes
anybody in here so he takes the photos
back to barbara and she immediately said
that's him that's the guy and it was
rudy and apparently she had never seen
him before
so it turns out that rudy worked at the
club several years earlier
and that the club had had an illegal
casino going like in the back only kind
of your high roller people or your
special customers and stuff like that
only they were allowed to go back there
like it was these sort of like high
roller people
yeah they had all kind of like they had
all kind of machines and all kind of
[ __ ] back there but they didn't like
most of the people that went to the club
just normally didn't know about it so
rudy allegedly made a bunch of money
from the casino like from tips and stuff
but the cops raided the place in 1958.
and although rudy didn't get arrested or
anything like that um he suddenly wasn't
making nearly as much dough as he had
been making
so he was immediately under a bunch of
financial stress
and then he started developing stomach
ulcers like over the next following
years and in 1968
he was diagnosed with cancer
now there had also been some rumors
going around that he had stolen some
money from the club i don't know if
that's true or not most of the people
that
because i was reading this other article
that you know by somebody that wrote it
that had interviewed like people that
had actually known rudy when he was
alive and everybody said he was just
like an awesome dude so i don't know if
that's true or not but that's what they
said on the show so i'm saying
so what ended up happening apparently
rudy um you know because he was in so
much pain all the time because he had
cancer because he was in all these
financial difficulties and had been for
several years he went in the back office
and essentially shot himself in the head
yeah now he i think in the show it
showed that he died immediately but i
think in real life um he lived
for a few days maybe like in a coma i
was in a coma though i think yeah i'd
see he didn't wake up that'd been
horrifying but yeah that's just kind of
like yeah i think dudes oh i know i know
yeah but
yes i think in the in the show they just
kind of showed him like with the shotgun
and like he just quickly like put them
in there's a case in louisiana
where uh
some kid some trailer park kid
went nuts got pissed off at his family
killed him off a shotgun shot himself
underneath and then he shot himself
right underneath the jaw blew his face
off but he didn't kill him
yeah he survived yeah i remember hearing
about that yeah
how [ __ ] horrible he's in prison
without a face with no face just eyes
and a slit
yikes
i mean probably nobody messes with him
though because he probably looks scary
[ __ ]
although if that was me i would probably
i mean not that i would ever do that i'm
just saying that if that was if my face
got shaved off in some accident or
something i mean i'd be like ooh
opportunity to wear all kind of like
scary masks and [ __ ] i could be a super
villain got the angle wrong just put his
chin underneath there just [ __ ] blew
his [ __ ] up didn't kill him what sure
look [ __ ] did like that
well you know
yeah
the pro tip yeah
make sure you got the angle right i mean
yeah because that would i mean if you
really want to do it i mean at least
with that dude man [ __ ]
life is worse than death
he's getting his issue yeah i mean
that's horrible yeah
so
so yeah so rudy died in the back office
and apparently uh rudy is still haunting
this place because barbara saw him
so dusty told them that rudy had also
been a catholic so tom figures uh you
know tom's also a catholic that rudy
might be trapped between the planes as
it were since suicide is such a big sin
in catholicism like maybe he can't go
one place or the other place
um and bill also surmised that rudy's
violent death was maybe making him act
out more violently and that someone
might end up getting hurt like i said
because of the glass throwing and [ __ ]
like that
so one very busy weekend night the
compressor on the beer tap uh suddenly
loses pressure so bill has to go down to
the basement again to fix him basements
are always creepy especially in a
haunting episodes
now while he was down there he noticed
that all the lights were out and they
wouldn't come on like presumably all of
the power was still working in the rest
of the club but in the basement he
couldn't get the lights to come on
now on the show
uh it actually showed him hearing kind
of like a raspy moan sound like
breathing or some [ __ ] behind him and
then rudy's ghost with the back of his
head blown off appears behind him but of
course bill didn't say he'd seen that
they just like put that on the show to
be scarier because it's like ooh look
here's the head with the back of it
missing
so uh bill by this point uh convinced
the place is haunted like no duh but is
too embarrassed to bring
it up with uh one of the owners philip
dean which is what they called him on
the show he was like the owner also the
landlord
within a few weeks though
philip the owner has a heart attack and
dies
and barbara at that point finally tells
bill and tom
that's why i couldn't tell you like the
ghost told me that one of the owners was
gonna die and i thought he was talking
about you guys
but now that phillip died
um she's like well i guess i can tell
you she's like i know this is gonna
sound shitty but she's like i was
actually kind of relieved she's like i
was you know obviously it was like sad
that like phillip died but
she's like
i was afraid that it was going to be
bill or tom and i really liked them and
it's like so i was glad it wasn't them
but
bill and tom on the other hand they're
like well we don't really want to take
chances because maybe the ghost actually
caused phillips death rather than
predicting it and
you know maybe he's trying to kill all
of us so you know they don't know they
don't know brian smith made his first
live chat with us
live chat brian
uh murder hornet's nest um
got his shirts today i verified that
with him oh okay good i uh you notice i
told you i threw you a couple extra free
shirts in there man they were rejects
the image didn't quite come out as good
i would have normally thrown it away i
said oh [ __ ] i'm gonna give b i'm like
i'm gonna give [ __ ] murder hornets
some extra clothes to wear some extra
clothes yeah cause i know what it does
is wear my t-shirts i sent it
[Laughter]
well you know yeah and uh i guess that's
it is there anything else going on okay
super chats are active if you all want
to uh
tip jenny you can just uh drop a super
chat in and if you're interested in any
kind of shirts we can talk about it
right here [ __ ] i think 20 i'll send
you a shirt
later on i'll get your address whatever
size it is what pattern you want all
right got a bunch of stuff okay
so at this point like tom suggests maybe
we should bring in a priest like to
bless the police
and he happened to know a guy from high
school whose name was gary dilly he's
also on the show uh he's a roman
catholic priest
so he said that shortly after he entered
the first enter the club he said he felt
an ice-cold chill
uh he described it as though someone had
left the door of a walk-in freezer open
he also said and i remember you noting
that he said this uh the quote was you
could feel
expectations yeah that was the word that
he used yeah
like someone's watching something's
gonna happen
yeah like it was just kind of you're
right heavy like kind of always felt
camp guy got his t-shirt staged
like what did you think you
said very happy with that okay good
yeah because they the male picked them
up on friday so yeah everybody should
probably be getting them right he got i
think a cannon and a um
snake pliskin i think
on it yeah
one of them
yeah i think so
okay
uh so dilly uh dilly he's a dilly bar i
wonder if anybody calls him that
that's what i would call him yeah
do they still have a dilly bar at um
where the [ __ ] is that at
what's that ice cream place
what ice cream place
[ __ ] swensons no 31 flavors no
carvels no
baskin robbins no
baskin robbins 31 flavors i think are
the same thing thank you very much thank
you
we'll order more shirts soon okay okay
cool whatever you want man i'll send it
to you dairy queen dairy queen
yeah
that's who had the dilly bar but i don't
know if they still have it i haven't
been to dairy queen for probably 25
years
uh so i'm just going off on a thing
diddly bar so
i just like to say that so he
so he walks the whole place by himself
and said he felt very strongly that
someone was with him like someone was
like next to him the whole time so he
brings in two other priests the priest
posse as it were
and they do a blessing
now the editing gotta say was pretty
dramatic here um you know while they're
just going through reading
prayers which you know admittedly is
pretty boring
they have flashbacks of rudy shooting
himself
you know creepy shots of ghosts lights
flashing on and off like the blinds kind
of shaking and that kind of stuff i
don't know if any of that stuff happened
i doubt it they take liberties with
these they do but like i said you gotta
make a show you can't just have like a
bunch of priests standing around going
uh yeah
like i said
that would be like super boring so they
have to like make it look like some
[ __ ] something's happening you know
what i mean while they're doing it uh so
tilly bar is afraid i'm just gonna call
him that is afraid that the prayers are
making the spirits angry which it's yeah
he's seen like some other episodes of
haunting because that's always what
happens you go in there like priests go
in there it just stirs all the [ __ ] up
you make it worse you just make it worse
so at least he knows now in this case
they didn't but i'm just gonna say like
he thinks well if they get mad
then if all of us living [ __ ]
are like standing around in here like
maybe it'll possess somebody and nobody
wants that so
he is
i don't know why this made me laugh so
much and it made me laugh again when i
was like watching it because i watched
it again today a second time so i could
take more notes on it so he's like so
they're doing the thing
and then he's like we have to get out of
here like right now
and so like nothing special happened he
was just like we have to get out of here
so they run the hell out of the club
immediately and they're kind of like and
they go across the street and bill i
think says it's just like why the [ __ ]
do we have to get it is going to blow up
or something and he said that the priest
said well it's a possibility yeah it's
not going to blow up it's a possibility
it could blow up
the deal imagine that
i'm [ __ ] well okay technically it could
blow up but not from ghosts yeah and i'm
like 99.999 think about it
it's not going to blow up
based on all my research i saw one of
the [ __ ] best top-notch [ __ ]
classic poltergeist events the [ __ ]
only thing better would have been
[ __ ] uh um maybe winfield or
enfield poltergeist
imagine
what would happen if you find these
houses that are exploded
okay around around the world
explosion
find this [ __ ] exploded house right
so they call out [ __ ] pbi post blast
investigation
they start put setting a grid down and
[ __ ] [ __ ] put a grid down and they're
looking for the bomb parts they never
find any [ __ ] thing don't you think
you'd hear about that well yeah then
you'd have be like we believe that
they're covering it up man they believe
that this house blew up through [ __ ]
explosive poltergeist phenomena
but yeah ghosts blow [ __ ] up i ain't
gonna buy that and i've seen some
[ __ ] badass poultry guys but blow up
a house no
please tell me within the character of
it please tell me that somebody has made
a movie called ghost explosion
in which yes exactly that happens
now okay there's only one way
from personal experience based on
personal experience i'm trying to say
how could a poultry guys blow up a house
uh the only way i could ever see it
doing is it would blow out the pilot
light while you weren't home and fill
the house yeah see like i could see that
and then yeah and then somehow [ __ ] but
i mean cause of fire technically that's
not the ghost blowing he's not
indirectly causing the house to blow up
right he's not actually physically
blowing up so if there was if there was
an investigation they would say well
it's gas leak they wouldn't say poultry
guys yeah exactly but i think in the
mind of that priest he's thinking oh no
dramatic forces i've seen ghosts blow up
houses blow the house right the [ __ ] up
yeah
i don't know why the i think it was
because he was so serious yeah like what
do you say everyone i remember remember
i don't know what
well it could blow up i'm like no it's
not good
like i said it yeah it's pot
it could blow up but it's not gonna have
anything one of the great things about
about the haunting series they did [ __ ]
it was just completely they just do [ __ ]
like that
i love i wish that i would have been
there because apparently so 19 it's 1974
everybody's probably wearing like
horrible shirts with big collars and
have like you know white man afros and
big bell bottoms to shake or whatever
and big porn stashes and so
they run out the club that like three
priests like in tow and then they
standing across the street from the club
for like half an hour like looking at
the [ __ ] like waiting for it to blow
yeah they're here
waiting for it to blow i don't know if
they did that i'm imagining but yeah
that's that's what i pictured oscar
[ __ ] jenny's going to send a cash out
jenny got a set of cash out okay thank
you all right thank you
that's cool yeah jenny's got cash app
too if you all want to send her a tip i
got cash app i got pictures show us some
show us the cash
show us some of them flash bulbs we love
the flash bulbs
little mini miniature paydays every day
[Laughter]
too many i don't pay for [ __ ] but you
know what i mean
it does kind of add up a little bit they
help they help well everything helps
yeah
i thought i was going to have to mow the
lawn today but it rained and it saved me
from the [ __ ] hassle of having to do
it well now well and that it sucks
because now because it rained and now
it's going to make the grass grow faster
which will right and what you'll need
more fuel efficiency okay more grass to
be out there
so i've cut it on this new three
thousand dollar lawnmower
you better be using that [ __ ] three
thousand dollars three thousand
three thousand 000 lawnmower that y'all
are paying for
well not really i mean
well lots of different things yeah for
it we would have had to pay a hundred
dollars a month 150 a month anyway for
grass crew i know so it's just it's just
better to pay for that [ __ ] in a couple
years we'll be free of it it's just me
and last so this summer has been kind of
hard i get well like it's not so much
it's just that we've had like a lot more
expenses like i said because we had to
buy that and then like you know the
electric bill is always higher nearly a
thousand dollars in damn air conditioner
[ __ ] that kind of crap yeah and it's
just you know
next year though
my va benefits for uh
[ __ ] uh disabled veteran though makes
me tax free when it comes to yeah you
know properly property that saves us
three hundred dollars a month yeah
that's that'll be very much that'll be a
big help yeah that'll be a big help
so that'll start january and i mean
honestly we've even i mean it's gotten
kind of easier so you know this house is
kind of expensive but
it's not that much more expensive than
our old one and in a way like because we
live so much farther away from stuff
we've been doing less stuff because it's
just like so far so it's like i hardly
ever have to buy gas because we never go
anyplace i can't believe
i can't believe that the energy bills
are the same
i can't believe it either but like i
said this house is more a lot better
yeah
it's a lot more insulated but uh yeah so
we got distracted by the ghost explosion
yeah please tell me i mean please tell
me something somebody has to have made
that movie come on it's going to have
somebody's made every movie
it's going to have sharks in it too
yeah that's what black frog said it
sounds like it'd be a shark named
ghostbusters explosion i mean well
they've done like every combination of
well they've done every combination of
everything with a shark and everything
with well we saw ouija shark you
remember that one it was terrible that
was awful
i mean it was like a shark puppet no i'm
gonna go ahead and get it like the idea
is funny
but the craziest best craziest movie out
there
what well i'm gonna give it i'm gonna
give it say it's the best one
is um
[ __ ] uh the velocipaster philosopher
philosophy god i love philosophers it's
just so good it's so lovable i just love
that writing is really good it's so fun
i mean like i said it's it's
deliberately like a very cheap movie but
yeah i mean how can you not love
a movie about a priest that turns into
like a were dinosaur come on i mean it's
just it's so awesome it's just so
awesome
uh but yeah so they all run out they're
standing around obviously the place
doesn't blow up and i kind of feel like
this one
as good of an episode as this was like
the ending was kind of
anti-climactic because normally what you
see with these episodes is that they're
like well we had you know like all of
this paranormal shenanigans or whatever
and then we had to bring in a priest or
the ghost hunters or whatever the [ __ ]
so they bring somebody in they do some
sage or some blessings or something and
then it's like oh everything was fine
for like
a little while and then woo like [ __ ]
[ __ ] went crazy again and it got even
worse and then like we had to run out
the house like
like the amityville thing and like leave
all the furniture there and stuff
but this one basically the three priests
came in they did their thing they waited
outside waiting for it to blow up
nothing happened and then they went back
in and they're like oh everything's fine
you know what i mean so it was just kind
of like oh all right and then like
apparently
if it was indeed rudy's ghost that was
haunting the place uh he
i guess moved on to
whatever like the next plane of
existence and didn't bother anybody
anymore and as far as i know there was
no other paranormal activity reported
after that and like i said
this isn't even one of those things
where
um where this location had like a [ __ ]
ton of
rumors about it or ghost stories about
it prior to
these people coming there because i
guess
when they opened the club
well the thing about it was that rudy
and like i said i don't really believe
in ghosts necessarily but
i mean if rudy was the one haunting it
he died in 1968
and then the club was closed not too
long after that
and
so and then it was empty like so it's
like the owner still kept it up and
everything but it wasn't open to the
public so it wasn't open to the public
again until 1974 when like the two guys
started running it and they opened it
again
so
i mean it stands to reason that there
hadn't been any reports of the ghosts in
there before because nobody had really
been in there like to any great extent
interestingly it doesn't really seem
like
people that came to the club
that i know of like reported anything
weird it was mostly just people that
were there all the time like the
managers and the employees which i guess
makes sense
but um
but yeah so apparently uh that kind of
solved the problem the priest saved the
day
um and they said that only about six
months after that though like after and
i think this is well the thing about it
they didn't really say how long the like
the span of time that this was but i
think that when
they ended up closing it i think it was
like 1979 so even though
even though on the show it made it look
like oh my god they were open for like
five minutes and then like they closed i
think it was like five years i think
uh so because i think it closed again in
1979. yeah block frog there was a movie
called ouija shark and it was if you
[ __ ] around with this ouija board
[ __ ] in another dimension a
ghost-like shot goes shark would come
after you and [ __ ] get you well it
was a ghost shark puppet yeah it looked
terri
the title is better than the [ __ ]
movie though that's what i mean the
concept was like way better than the
execution
how to do it right
it's real cheap but one thing they did
was they did show you a bunch of like
bikini girls and girls with implants and
boobs i mean there was like super super
long scenes of like yeah girls in
bikinis like washing cars and yeah yeah
they knew that that was the only way
they would get you
it was shot on somebody's cell phone it
and it to watch
did yeah yeah i mean like just local
strippers
yeah yeah it was just kind of like yeah
it wasn't like super super oh and what
would have been great is if they'd had a
script it would have been cool it's
their
i was researching the haunting of the
crash site of flight 191 in 1979 this
weekend very creepy when are you done a
show on it we have not i haven't even
like heard about that but i'm going to
write that down right now yeah you enjoy
your shirt next dimension yeah
just hopefully hopefully it should have
got there yeah should be getting there
okay flight 91 flight 191 rather yeah
1979. all right so now as i mentioned
okay so he said six months after the
priest came and did the blessing and did
the thing and everything was fine he
said business kind of started to decline
and like i said they ended up closing
down a little while after that but like
i said even on the show it seemed like
not that long a time i think it was like
five years i think it closed again in
like 1979.
so that was like pretty much the end of
the show now
i found another write-up about this
place
uh on another website called american
hauntings inc
and it kind of talked about it said the
late club actually opened um as a
nightclub in 1940
but that building prior to that had been
like some restaurants and a skating rink
and like some other [ __ ] but 1940 they
actually opened it as a as a nightclub
and there was like a whole bunch of like
really famous uh acts there you know
what i mean i think i mentioned some
before bob hope pearl bailey you know
spike jones nelson eddie everybody like
that so everybody was there and it was
like a huge huge success
um they even had like a radio show
back in the old days that you know uh
broadcast from there a whole a whole
kind of thing so it was going for like
20 years and it did like really well um
and again they had like this illegal
gambling [ __ ] going on in the background
uh you know in the back room which
obviously they weren't supposed to have
and as i mentioned earlier that was true
that they did do a police raid in 1958
and um they said that
they came in the back and like the
people in the front like dancing and
watching the band and stuff didn't even
know what the [ __ ] was going on back
there because they didn't know about it
but yeah so they did um so they did a
raid
and then it ended up like uh
you know business kind of started
declining after the raid
and then it ended up
they ended up closing the doors and so
like i said it was because
when it reopened again in the 60s that's
when rudy worked there and that's when
he ended up and he ended up killing
himself and then in 1968 they closed it
and then it didn't reopen again until
1974.
and then after
those guys had it the guys on the show
like it got closed down again
uh and then in 1980 like somebody else
leased it and opened it as a rock club
and then in 1988 they closed it down for
good and then in 1992 it burned down and
they discovered that the fire had been
arson yeah those insurance wires got
crossed must be it's like yeah because
it had been empty for a while i don't
know who owned it at that point yes one
of the biggest one of the biggest
sources of all fires in mississippi is
uh
insurance wires getting crossed
yeah yeah i guess yeah mississippi's
arson capital
world you know what's interesting is
that the lake club i don't know i'm not
clear on
whether it was called the lake club
during the time period that we're
talking about like on a haunting because
on this other site it said in 1980 when
this story came out the
club was known as the sober duck rock
and disco club
which is a terrible terrible name
sober duck what does that even mean is
that an illinois thing a silver duck no
sober sober duck a sober duck
it's not a drunk duck it's a silver duck
i think drunk duck would be better yeah
[Laughter]
because i can see the logo now maybe
there was a drunk duck
already so there's a winner but see
sober duck sounds like you don't want to
go to that club
if it used to be called the drunk duck
that was the fun one and now it's the
sober one and it's like all we sell is
shirtley temperature raccoon raccoon you
want to show that yeah show that raccoon
again
[Music]
[Laughter]
where is that raccoon yeah do this [ __ ]
well i was just get what do that [ __ ]
again do it again
[Music]
we can't hear it actually yeah we can
maybe i should turn up the volume
now
now now we can hear it
yeah there you go there it is because i
have the volume down
could you could you guys hear the
raccoon i think they should have been it
should have been but they should have
been able to yeah but we couldn't hear
it on because because my volume is down
but uh yeah i was it's funny because i
was like i know that i have that audio
clip somewhere because when we did the
show about summer wind i pulled it out
of the episode
um because i wanted to put it in the
show and i was just like looking and
looking and i just spent entire case you
know how i do i just spent entirely too
long like i know i have that [ __ ]
audio clip somewhere and in my dropbox
from our old haunting of summerwind show
i didn't have just the clip but i found
the whole
uh the whole audio of our show that we
did on hunting of summer when so then i
had to just like scrub through there and
like find where that one little clip was
and then like kind of take it out i
wanted to also get a clip of that dude's
face
that actually face too he was on a bunch
of episodes so it's that guy
that's a
that's still my favorite episode out of
the entire series the summer wind even
though
they made a lot of that [ __ ] up you know
it for for the series you know i mean
it's just or a lot of the cool things
about it
that episode
were kind of
pulled out and pulled out of the air by
the [ __ ] uh by the by the team
because a lot had to do with the way the
house looked if you saw the real summer
wind then you go like oh okay that's why
nobody wanted to work on it it was a
[ __ ] wreck man because they're like
why i mean why didn't you just tear the
whole thing down and start over here
it's just like a bunch of clapboard yeah
it looked like a clapboard mansion yeah
essentially there was just nothing there
so
they're showing this pretty mansion that
has some [ __ ] thrown out on the lawn
and they're telling you nobody wants to
work on it and i'm going we're talking
about man the house looks [ __ ] great
but you just so that added to the sense
of mystery through this whole like
everybody knows it's haunted yeah and
that they were burning furniture to stay
a [ __ ] to stay warm in there because
dude would refuse to work and
[ __ ] so you're you're picturing him
in this [ __ ] nice match and burning
the furniture no man
there's probably worthless ass [ __ ]
old furniture inside that [ __ ] shack
it's a giant shack the size of a [ __ ]
yeah they're probably just like pulling
wood yelling off the wall yeah
just like it's all termite written it
kind of gives it a different
it gives the whole thing a different
[ __ ] yeah because like if some
workmen pulled up in the door well there
wasn't even a driveway it's like hold up
a friend would be like yeah no you're
like yeah
nope
yeah and if you're saying go to a
[ __ ] beautiful home then you go like
yeah there's some weird [ __ ] that's
weird but when you saw what summer would
look like you understood why they were
like it basically looked like a
mansion-sized outhouse yeah that's what
it looked like imagine size shack
falling down
so they would show up and go man turn
that [ __ ] down
tear that [ __ ] up like i said might as
well just start over and eventually
somebody just burned it down
i mean
yeah and now it's just like a chimney
yeah and
some of the online
some of the online rumors was that the
neighbors burned it down because they
got sick people [ __ ] tourists going
in there to look at that old [ __ ]
shack
so it did something whatever they're
there dude you went over there and
burned the [ __ ] down
yeah you're out in the middle of nowhere
anyway you could burn something down
didn't matter and then he said well
lightning struck it
lightning didn't strike it the neighbors
burned it down because they wanted
people to get away maybe the neighbor's
name was lightning yeah did you ever
think of that yeah
the foundation was left lightning struck
it i mean lightning is my nickname so
the foundation was left behind
but this you look at the stones and the
mortar and everything that that they
used it was low quality
the whole thing was low quality was
never
i think it probably looked okay
in its early years when they first built
it but it wasn't made out of stuff to
last that's why it looked like that it
just fell apart it was made cheap
sebastian said uh we should do some
halloween three t-shirts
we probably should halloween three oh
yeah oh yeah i could come with that i
mean yeah we could come up with as long
as we don't know the shamrock shirt is
what you want yeah i mean yeah and i've
seen those before like yeah but the
pumpkin or whatever yeah as long as we
don't get into trouble with like uh
copyright but i guess it doesn't really
matter like it doesn't really matter
we're not selling them like on stores or
anything yeah could we because a lot of
the [ __ ] that we do would violate
copyright in a way these are these are
custom handmade creations they're not
mass-produced this is bootleg [ __ ] yes
art
and we're only selling them to friends
right they're not sold we're not selling
to the public yeah we're not necessarily
not something to the public
i mean in as much as you guys are yeah
yeah y'all are the public we're in our
house
yeah i mean if you look for something i
can hook you up with it we'll hook it
i'll make something block frog says
another good audio clip from the raccoon
guy is when he's playing the organ and
it's like i don't care i'll play all
night yeah yeah
i don't know
i don't
care that [ __ ] guy was great
that was great man
yeah
and that crazy
weird music i was like that's kind of
pretty yeah the way the whole thing was
said the way the way they characterized
the case
it was my favorite episode and most of
it had to do with the way the the
haunting
crew
characterized everything
it's not the way it really was if you
saw it and i guarantee you it wasn't it
was well nothing on that show is none of
the stories behind it because every
single
time that we've talked about an episode
yeah and i was able to find like
interviews like in newspapers or stuff
like that with the actual people
they to a man they always say well the
show was exaggerated or they put stuff
in there that didn't really happen or
they edited it weird or something like
that and but uh if you ask me some the
summer win episode
that's way better than amnevil horror
way better
way better than a lot of some of the
sequels to emily viljor
it doesn't play as a [ __ ]
cinema
like a cinema type film it plays as a
documentary but that kind of layers in
the creepiness of it because it kind of
like presented as if it was factual
which i'm not saying something didn't
happen there it's just that it didn't
quite
look like that it didn't feel like that
something may have happened there
gotta go back i just i always kind of
notice because i know that when a
haunting comes there
and i
i don't know like exactly how they do
the [ __ ] but i know a little bit about
it because they did contact us about
doing the yeah
mammoth mountain thing yeah mountain
didn't really like the idea of a
poltergeist excuse me
a haunting really didn't
like
didn't like the idea of doing a
a poltergeist case
they're kind of more into like ghosts
like ghost or demons
like i kind of feel like they always
wanted to kind of get it into a
narrative where it's like oh people saw
or heard weird [ __ ] in there and then we
found out that there was like a little
kid that got murdered and like you know
was buried under the floorboards or
whatever so it's just always kind of
like i think they like that because it's
creepier i don't know if they
necessarily want to go like the
poltergeist no right
she was kind of subtly
encouraging me to change the story
and i was like that's not what happened
though
and they were like yeah but you know
we're not really because
our agreement with our contract is is
that this has to be a ghost
okay and it has to kind of fit the
narrative of all the other stories that
we have
which like i said that's fair enough
they have a show they have a template
they have a narrative that works for
them yeah and so if they have to kind of
like massage the things to like fit into
their story it was years ago man and
yeah it was a while she was the woman
that was the main director of the second
company that owned them and she wanted
to do it she read the book she wanted to
do it yeah she read our book and she
contacted us actually and she called us
a about her free book and she called us
she said about she wanted to do it but i
was just like no that's not what
happened i'm not going to you know
change it you know she was going to
understand and i said and i kind of was
[ __ ] with her a little bit towards
the end it says
so we're starting to you we're starting
a youtube channel and we're just going
to do what we want to do you know we
don't really
like like i said so we don't really need
to have anybody telling us how to do
things you know i mean when it comes to
stuff like this we can do it ourselves i
do what i want
no i'm not going to change the story
yeah i'm not going to change stories
i'll be live
i think that would be a really good
episode but but it wouldn't fit in with
all the episodes that i have previously
because like you said it's not like you
found out later oh somebody died in that
place or nothing it was nothing like
that no and then uh there was some some
shows where they said and it found out
that this is a poltergeist and [ __ ]
it did sound like a folger guy but then
they portray poltergeist just as a ghost
or a demon yeah they kind of use it like
the terminology interchangeably which
it's kind of not right no yeah it's it's
a totally different thing a poltergeist
is not a ghost nor a demon
it's rspk
it's a fake ghost well like i said i
think that's maybe why they want to
concentrate more on stuff that's a
little bit more esoteric
it's like we want something that
is recognizably like a ghost and you
find out that somebody like killed
themselves in the house which like i
said that's scary or
you find out it's like some kind of evil
demonic whatever and then you bring in
the warrens and they fix it told me it
had something to do with their
contracting and their licensing
just like uh the other ones where
haunted animals the haunted [ __ ] pets
one where on animal planet yeah on
animal planet i can't remember that they
have a shoehorn a pet in this story
somehow for licensing pro for licensing
yeah for licensing and it's really funny
and it's a a lot of the episodes it's uh
it's very obvious it's just she warned
in there because it's like five seconds
yeah oh by the way the family had a dog
and the dog was like
like looking in the corner one time and
it was crazy right yeah and then by the
way the goldfish
the goldfish was very disturbed
[Laughter]
it was like
and then you never hear about the
goldfish
poor goldfish and then they interviewed
yeah the goldfish i looked and the
goldfish was swimming around in a circle
like that
its eyes were like this and his mouth
was doing it
obviously it was seeing some like
obviously singing the ghost it was it
was chasing a ghost in a circle it was a
little bitty tiny aquatic ghost and it
was like chasing but um no i made sure
that we sent a copy of it that's another
movie i made sure we sent a copy of
mammoth to [ __ ]
the haunting
and now they responded right away a
couple weeks because she ran it she said
i read the book it's a great book but i
don't know how we're going to do this
because this and then this and that it's
not like it's not really
she's i'd like to have it on but i mean
it's scary but it has to do with this
and that and then she wanted to do an
interview with lois and red and lois and
red didn't want anybody in their house
they absolutely did they said we don't
want these people in our house we don't
know these people because we don't even
know if we want so that was another
thing where they didn't really want to
be on tv and so i tried to negotiate a
little bit and she's like uh you know we
don't want to be on tv man
and lois is like my sisters would never
i never hear the end of it
yeah because her sisters were [ __ ]
religious fanatics i mean they could
have told her that she could have like
because some of the people the one that
we watched the other day which we might
do an episode on i can't remember what
the name of it was but the one about the
guy with the apartment and like how his
girlfriend was in there and she was sad
all the time yeah she got yeah that one
um that guy didn't want his real name on
there and he was just like they're in
shadow and like his voice was a little
bit disguised so it's like if you wanted
to be anonymous on there they will let
you then it does happen and then red
died
yeah was the best witness he remembered
more than i did
lois wasn't that good of a witness she
claimed to remember things that i know
didn't happen
like she said she saw the damn piece of
twist tie go up and write the word go on
the window that did not happen
i said no way lois i walked up and found
that twist tie in the [ __ ] well yeah
that's what you told me yeah i found it
there and i was and i was like you said
it was already written it was already
written and that you went up and she
goes no i saw it right and i said no no
no remember yeah i found it and i called
you and you you and red came up the
stairs to see it
oh no i saw it write that and i was just
like no
now red said no red said no lois it was
like that he showed it to us but then
she was like adamant no i saw it right
well that's that's how she remembered it
and the thing about it is she imagined
that happening
yeah i'm getting that happening and
remembered it as if it was real
because that's how she pictured it
happened
well that's kind of the that's kind of
the issue too is that it happened such a
long time ago and people everybody has a
tendency to
add on to their memories over time
so you know and embellish
a little bit some people more than
others and wesley wesley's memory of it
was vague and
and
well you said he didn't really pay that
much attention yeah and he was
uncomfortable there he was scared he
didn't really want to talk about it
lois said later weeks later he was
scared to sleep by himself and something
was bothering him
well he actually did before i wrote the
book
he actually did
write like a letter like write a thing
of like what he remembered which wasn't
a lot because like i said he wasn't
really basically kind of like poetry he
said he said he said he felt flapping
wings above him yeah yeah yeah and i put
that in the book too i put that in the
book too like he said he experienced
some things like in his room by himself
but i did hear the [ __ ] from him though
yeah i don't know what he's talking
about
yeah i think he just saw that himself or
that's what he claimed i don't know i
don't think he said he saw that i think
he said he felt killed wings
over his head or yeah like while he was
laying it back where he was laying in
bed you didn't he didn't want to look at
it or something i i don't know
maybe he was talking about wind and he
imagined wings were flapping i don't
know what he was seeing
and but he was scared i know he was
scared
he was he was scared of it
it was weird real weird
danny rowling says the haunting episode
where the kids venture into supposedly
haunted graveyard and test out some of
the sites see if they're actually on it
was a good episode
that was legend trippers yeah legend
trooper somebody yes
was involved in legends
yeah i wrote it down that'll be one that
will do i mean a couple people like i
said this late club horror was one that
a lot of people uh recommended and um
there was a couple other ones that i
wrote down over there i think were like
when darkness falls or whatever that's
there and so we're gonna do those and
then we might do legend trippers as well
weird thing about wes
is i brought that up one day this is
years after it happened yes i guess so
probably six seven years ago eight years
maybe we know yeah how long ago was that
we started writing
yeah man when did that book come out
about eight years ago something like
that
i think 2015 i think i published that
yeah and and i brought it up to him i
hadn't talked to wesley and we did we
did we're just typing over online you
know he's deaf he can't talk
and i said wesley you remember the uh
remember the ghost at baby mountain and
he goes oh yeah yeah no that didn't
happen
he goes red made that up and i said no
it didn't
that happened he was like that happened
and i said you don't you remember this
happened and that happened he's like oh
yeah yeah that happened and i was like
yeah that happened he was in denial well
it's weird because he like i said he
wrote a thing and he
described that it happened and i said
don't you remember how that back thing
and he's had that back room with that
drafting table and he goes yeah that was
evil you know he would just say yeah
that was scary that was evil so he was
afraid of it but he didn't know what it
was and he was going into denial and he
goes so red didn't make that up
and i said no he didn't make that up you
remember it we were there and and you
know i was just typing this moved and
that moved and you turned around and you
saw it and it wasn't there anymore i was
just giving it you know this remember we
would run up the stairs like something
was chasing us he goes yeah it was there
was evil behind us
you know
it's just he's deaf and slightly
autistic so he had a hard time making
sense out of what he was seeing
you know he wasn't paying close
attention but he looked like he was
having a fever
i can't explain it i think he was
shutting down because it was spooking
him out
so he was just kind of withdraw
withdrawing into [ __ ] like
sleep and being lethargic either that or
some in some weird way
the psychokinetic
energy or whatever it is that does it
was draining him i don't know what it
was you know i mean maybe that kind of
was the impression i was getting from
what lois
because she's training him that yeah she
said he just like slept all the time
yeah and that when he slept he looked
like a dead person yeah he did he looked
really weird the whole he looked like he
was a corpse i mean she told me that
multiple times yeah it was like
something was shutting him down or he
was shutting himself down and i was
getting like
i was in an extreme manic
state it was
definitely
something having to do with quantum
consciousness it was it was a it was a
it was a it was a
some kind of quantum effects of
consciousness stuart hammer off [ __ ]
yeah it was weird
you saw a little bit of it imagine it
like oh man
seven eight nine times that strength
that was only gonna be a big pain in the
end yeah it was like 14. and it's kind
of
ominous and threatening
you know but then sometimes it gets kind
of playful it was weird really weird
but yeah um well let me go back to like
lit club for a second because
there was some stuff that they didn't
put on the show i already mentioned that
barbara the bartender
actually said that when she saw the
apparition in the office it wasn't
actually like a whole body it was just a
floating head which like i said would
have been way scarier right so maybe
they should put it on the show another
thing they didn't show on the show like
they did kind of show like glasses
flying around and stuff but one of the
other
uh women that were i don't know if it
was the same it's just you know the site
just said a waitress so i don't know if
it was barbara if it was somebody else
that worked there
said one night she went to like give a
drink to a customer and then the glass
was actually filled with chocolate
even though it had just been normally
clean like before it's filled with
chocolate chocolate what chocolate milk
i'm guessing or chocolate syrup i
thought chocolate syrup chocolate syrup
probably maybe but they said that was
like really weird i was like that
sounded like some [ __ ] your poltergeist
yeah it's political guys type stuff like
where it's just like suddenly hey
oh
[ __ ] um steve dr steve merritt i'm
gonna call him dr dr steve but i don't
think he is a doctor
but um
steve would say that there's a lot of
crossover between some hauntings and and
some poltergeist
that some some hauntings produce
poltergeist-like effects in other words
moving objects
in general i've been in a bad house
before later on i talked about that
earlier
over in massachusetts nothing ever moved
it was just a bad house
bad dreams
bad feelings not just me other people
guests
but nothing ever moved
nothing physical just all emotional
but somehow i think it was a haunting i
don't have proof but it's just feelings
you know
um
but some hauntings are strong enough to
where objects would move
i haven't seen it but that's what they
say
like a poultry guys
you know what's weird it's like the only
i've never really experienced that like
going into a house and being like oh man
this place is like really bad energy or
whatever yeah i've had it happen to me
one time not in a house but in a store
i went in a store it was a big lot
actually you told me about that yeah in
daytona
and i was in there
buying something for my house like some
[ __ ] tupperware or something like
that and i was in there and all of a
sudden i was like oh man i gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here like right now and i
was just like and i didn't know why it's
like everything just felt like very
impressive and i had never had that
feeling ever um but i was just like yeah
[ __ ] it i gotta get out of here i just
knew i had to get out of here i don't
know why yeah that's the only time
that's happened and then i had one thing
happen
at my grandmother's old house which like
i said you know i never thought it was
hard i lived there for years and years i
never felt weird in there or nothing but
i was sitting at the dining room table
one day and i swore to god that somebody
was like standing behind me
and i had never felt that before
ever like in that house and that was the
only time that happened and i was like
what the [ __ ] and like i turned around
and obviously no one was there and then
i thought to myself well my
grandfather's ashes were like in the
in the cabinet back there so it's like
maybe it was him i was like i don't know
why he'd be standing behind me like he
never did that before he didn't die in
the house he died in the hospital but
there was that but the thing about it is
that for many years
i lived in my grandfather's old house
which
my mom and her siblings most of them had
grown up in
and they insisted to me this place is
super haunted they told me
that my mom told me this my aunts told
me this they said um our covers got torn
off all the time like in the middle of
the night
uh they heard footsteps on the roof all
the time like walking back and forth on
the roof all that kind of stuff but i
lived in that house for a really long
time and i never felt anything in that
house i actually love that house it was
creepy like if
it i don't know it it seemed like a like
a creepy house if you were like thinking
oh what does a creepy house look like
but i never felt creepy in there i never
i was never scared of the house or
anything like that even though i knew
all the stories about it i never felt
weird in there
not ever that one house that me and eric
lived in after we got out of the army it
was in arlington massachusetts right
outside uh medford i think this was near
um
medford or somerville
but um i could find it on the map i
forgot what the i think i might have i
forgot the address
anyway um i could find it on google
earth
it's an old victorian house victorian
era house late 1800s
it just had a very still
sad feeling of
kind of like being watched but just
still real
unnaturally still
and sad
and um
kind of
dark
you know there's only way i can describe
it nothing ever moved though it's weird
to the restroom
yeah
i'm trying to look i'm trying to look if
there's anything else about
late club that wasn't on the show
i kind of i just remembered like the the
floating head thing because i got hung
up on that because i was like why didn't
they show them the show that had been
like so creepy and then like the whole
glass of chocolate thing which i thought
was really weird and i was like that was
another thing that well like i said
maybe they didn't
you know and i'm not [ __ ] on the
show it's an entertainment show you know
what i mean they're not trying to be
like
super factual or anything they're just
trying to like entertain people and
creep them out so
you know the stories are real-ish it's
just that
they have a particular narrative a
particular
storyline that they're adhering to and
like anything that is a little bit weird
or a little bit random or something like
that they're not going to put that in
there so i think that that's kind of why
when they contacted us about doing
mammoth mountain on there
i think they wanted to sort of like i
said massage it into a narrative when
one of the things that i always thought
was really creepy when he first started
telling me i mean he first started
telling me about this like but i think
before he even started dating so
um he didn't want to tell me at first
because he thought that i would think
that he was making it up but um when he
did tell me about it i was actually
fascinated and i was just kind of like i
liked it because i thought it was
scarier because it was random because it
didn't have
a narrative like a horror movie so to me
it seemed like much more likely to be
true because i'm just kind of like you
know why would somebody just make up
like all these weird random
it's like it doesn't make any sense like
why would it
why would if it was a ghost like why
would it do all this kind of stuff but i
feel like a haunting and shows like that
even though they're not movies and
they're supposed to be
true stories they still want it to have
like a little bit of a three-act
structure like a regular movie
so they structure it more like a
fictional story and so they have to like
leave some details out so i think that's
maybe why and i was like i don't so i
don't know maybe that's why they left
out in the late club the whole like
thing about the chocolate glass of
chocolate cause they thought that would
be too goofy or it didn't like make any
sense like
because their whole narrative was this
is rudy the guy that blew his head off
and he's haunting the place and why
would rudy fill a glass with chocolate
you know what i'm saying so it's like i
guess that's why they left that out but
that was one thing that i came across
that somebody said that had happened
there that they didn't put in the show
oscar says he wants a silver scent
shamrock shirt we can work that we'll
find it we'll make one yeah i can make
one that's a good idea silver i mean i
remember the logo being pretty simple
and i could probably make or i could
even make like a variation on it
variation to be honest yeah
yeah
i mean show me what you're working on
and i want some input too but i think
you're right
um
i mean when i when i did the ocp one
yeah what i did for that one because i
wanted to look wanted it to look as
uh
as kind of like accurate as possible
yeah so i took a screenshot
from robocop yeah and just blew it up
big and then retraced it in illustrator
okay and that's why i made it so it's
like exactly like the logo but silver
shamrock because there are a bunch of
other
because silver shamrock isn't as far as
i know isn't copyrighted or anything
because it was just like in a movie so a
lot of other horror sites have done
silver shamrock shirts
you want it to be like recognizable as
that but
i don't know maybe it'd be cool to like
do another your own spirit
just show me what you took
i'll look i'll look at it and see like
what i'm looking at
i think it should be like a company
label it should be a shamrock and it
should be silver with the [ __ ] circle
with the circle around it yeah that's
what i was thinking
is written in it it ought to be great
yeah yeah even if it's in [ __ ] like
uh
the irish font that might be really cool
too
i'm trying to remember what font was it
what's what font did they use
i want to say it was kind of now maybe
not i was going to say it was like
[ __ ] american unseal or something
because i'm a fond dork sorry yeah
because
the guy that owned the company was irish
so i would think that it [ __ ]
would be cool if it was an irish font
with an irish theme and
yeah but spooky you know
we'll see let's see you can come up with
you know what's funny is that when i was
doing the the cards for these haunting
shows
i was like
uh
you know if you see like the early
seasons of a haunting
i immediately recognized what that font
was that they used for that i was like
oh that's herculeneum and uh and i have
that
check your cash app oh okay
well throw me my phone okay
throw me my phone
yeah it's still that the thing is like
really really short
oh it's live it's a live show i'm
checking right here
yep there it is i see it thank you very
much thank you very much thank you very
much
all right cool yeah it's there it's
there
i mean you know i didn't doubt it what's
up horror uk
yeah if you're interested in shirts i
could probably get them to the uk too
but it probably cost a little bit more
for shipping
yeah but i can still ship from the from
the house we can ship right man i'm so
[ __ ] glad everything i i invested
yeah in a postage scale
and i bought a printer a good one like i
got a good i got a good printer so i can
print out my own postage yeah and uh we
can mail out all over i'm pretty sure
they'll do international they'll just
pick it up from your porch yeah i mean
that's what i did for the last one i
just put them out on the porch and they
took it yeah we have to check we got to
check what the shipping costs are that
goes for anybody in europe
we have a lot of cool little shirts we
can do and they're all basically
semi-custom
i mean you won't see anybody else i mean
we shipped to the uk and like i've
shipped to australia and [ __ ] like that
before so i don't imagine it would cost
any more than if we went to the post
office and did it
same it'd be the same
it should be the same because i'm buying
the postage from the post office it's
the same they're just coming to my house
and picking it up instead of me going
there saving some gas
well yeah and like i said the
sadly the post office that is nearest to
us doesn't have self-service yeah so you
can't just like mail stuff from the
machine you actually have to go there
when it's open
like during open hours and like go in
there and wait in line and [ __ ] that
noise who the hell has time for that
oscar to make a successful shirt man
it's got to be first of all one color
all right
and the image has to be symmetrical so
it has to
it has to be kind of a symmetrical image
that looks like
like a symbol
okay
because that'll that that's more um
that appeals to a wider brand a customer
well and it looks decent in a nightclub
that's [ __ ] and it's easier for us to
do because honestly we just have white
ink um
and it comes out much better when it's
just like kind of like a bold bold
single one color design yeah we've tried
to do stuff like in a couple other
colors before and it's like really
really hard to get right because we
don't have all of the equipment for like
you know yeah lining all of this stuff
up and then you spend all this money on
a product that nobody buys
they'll actually they're more likely to
buy a single uh white on black they're
they're more likely to buy that so what
we decide i mean what we decided to do a
long time ago was that if we're going to
do like just custom shirts like that i
just want to do white ink on black on a
black shirt whereas if i want to do a
more complicated design then i'll do it
through zazzle or redbubble or something
like that because on there you can like
print anything because it's a digital
printer yeah but you got to worry about
copyrights
yeah for that like yeah
but
what we did like zazzle i did a bunch of
designs on there that are not
copyrighted and redbubble i did some
show it's like some [ __ ] for my uh for
my new sites like scare salon and crime
and memorial and stuff like i did shirts
and stuff for that because you can do
anything on there as long as you do a
design and it's like you upload the png
and it'll slap it on pretty much
anything you want the [ __ ] that we make
here
we don't make that much on it it's
basically uh
it's almost a labor of love it's more of
an advertisement
after you [ __ ] you know the shipping
cost how much it costs to do the shirt
and then the materials and everything
we're lucky to make two three bucks on
one
yeah we don't make a [ __ ] ton of money
on the shirts to be honest with you i
mean because like i said depending on
what kind of shirt it is what size it is
because obviously the larger the size
the more expensive they are and if it's
a [ __ ] white paper and i usually try
well and i usually try to get nicer
shirts i don't really like because
sometimes you can go to like jiffy
shirts and you can get like a plain
black shirt for like two or three bucks
but sometimes those
are not 100 cotton and 100 cotton ticks
ink better yeah so i usually try to get
the hundreds so usually those are
usually like five-ish bucks
and honestly i kind of like the softer
ones and those are usually slightly more
expensive yeah uh the ink isn't cheap
either so you know what i mean and then
the shipping and the cotton cotton takes
rit dye better so if you want to touch
that with black you can yeah i tend to
try to stick with like 100 cotton
because like i said it's it takes the
ink better
it's just better all around because they
do have cheaper shirts that are
partially cotton and partially like
other things like blends they're like
polyester [ __ ] so if your black shirts
ever start to fade you just
boil a bunch of water pour red in it
salt and throw your shirt in there
and uh you can boil all your black stuff
just throw it in the sink [ __ ] goths
know all about it and you can get the
red yeah you can get that at the grocery
store it's usually like an encounter
like right by the laundry [ __ ] the
hotter the water the more salt is in it
or you know you don't need a whole lot
of salt i used to have like a big
laundry tub and like every now and then
i throw all my clothes in there and if
it's if it's it'll retake the diet i'll
come out of there looking new danny
rowling said was rudy crainer the dead
ghost's real name as far as i know
yes that was the real guy that shot
himself in the club yeah i mean i don't
know if they changed it but i i saw like
on the on this other site that they used
that guy's name and they actually knew
the names of the owners that they
changed for the show so i'm assuming
that rudy crainer is that real that
guy's real name so we done
uh i guess so i don't think there's
anything else about it was there
anything else i think this is just kind
of like kind of like a re hash of the
show
yeah like and i already said like the
club burned down in 1992. but yeah
deliberately set like you said insurance
wires yeah insurance wires yeah so yeah
that's that's what happened with that so
insurance wires will cause [ __ ]
sparks every time that budget burned
down but ghosts aren't gonna blow it up
no probably i mean i don't want to say
that across the board because it could
happen like lots of things are possible
but it's like i don't know why i got so
hung up on that because little things
like that will just amuse me
ghosts are going to blow up your [ __ ]
you hungry
yeah all right i'm making some deep
barbecue pork sandwich
uh
okay i don't want any i don't want any
barbecue that's right you don't like
barbecue i don't like barbecue sauce
okay we gotta eat up the pork all right
well we just ha i can just have pork
with plain without okay all right uh
block frog says keep up the videos i
always enjoy them well thank you very
much we definitely will thank you so
tomorrow uh is tuesday so we'll be back
talking about another movie we're
probably gonna be talking about
pray the new predator
prequel yeah it's good uh which
premiered on hulu a couple of days ago
which actually yeah i quite enjoyed it i
thought yeah you can stream it but if
you have hulu you can see it for free if
you subscribe to hulu but you could
probably get there i think i think
they're allowing you to stream it
on uh
probably amazon well you can probably
find it other places but like i said i
have hulu i pay for hulu so i watched it
on there
zach said you don't like barbecue sauce
infidels [ __ ] crazy he likes barbecue
i don't dislike barbecue sauce it's just
that if you give me a choice of like
having it or not having it i would just
rather not
you know what i mean not really i don't
know it's like it's tangy things kind of
i like them sometimes but they give me a
really bad heartburn it's ridiculous and
it's just like i really can't well i
can't help it okay
it's just not and honestly like a lot of
times meat i don't like a lot of like
sauce or gravy or stuff like that on me
because i just want to like taste the
meat because i like meat you know okay
i'll get uh
all right so yeah we'll be back tomorrow
probably talking about pray so have a
good evening you guys and thanks for
dropping by thanks for super chats
thanks for hanging out with us and we
will see you again tomorrow evening